gleich in apulien fragen frau polieren
sie leiten hier in berlin eine
europäische denkfabrik wie wichtig sind
solche duelle sind sie ihr grundsätzlich
unwichtig und was bedeuten diese
umfragen auch hillary clinton war vor
vier jahren anführerin in den umfragen
aber sie hat ihr nicht genutzt
vielleicht fange ich mal mit den
umfragen an ich würde sagen seid 2016
sind alle leute meiner zunft ziemlich
bescheiden geworden was ihre prognose
fähigkeit betrifft 2016 lagen im prinzip
alle daneben und sie haben richtig
gesagt 2016 war hillary clinton im
september noch sieben prozentpunkte vor
trump genau wie jetzt joe biden nach den
umfragen aber dann hat es sich doch noch
anders entwickelt und wir sind 33 tage
vor der wahl alles ist möglich alles ist
offen das ist gibt viele fragen es kann
noch sehr viel passieren aber und sigmar
gabriel hat insofern einen guten punkt
gemacht mit der stabilität dieser
wahlkampf ist insofern interessant dass
die umfragen eigentlich stabil geblieben
sind
corona quotenhoch parteitage und
trotzdem gab es keinen signifikanten
wandel es sieht so aus als ob die
amerikaner in großen teilen ihre meinung
gebildet haben und jetzt wir einfach
abwarten und es keine veränderungen gibt
es geht jetzt wirklich nur um noch diese
unentschiedenen wechselwähler okay
und damit sind wir bei claus kleber
moderator des heute-journals usa kenner
korrespondent der usa seit 1984 klaus
natürlich tritt ließen ihn großartig
verfolgen die us-amerikanische wahlen
vor dieser sagen sie haben sie angst
warum weil ich im wort suchen muss das
schlimmer ist oder schwerer ist als
befürchtungen also man muss als reporter
und korrespondent in seiner
berichterstattung neutral sein aber
natürlich kann man nicht in einem land
leben und sagt es mir völlig wurscht wer
präsident wird und dieses mal habe ich
zum ersten mal angst weil ich glaube
dass also eine eine wiederwahl von trump
ist bei weitem nicht
der worst case
der worst case ist ein zusammenbruch des
amerikanischen gesellschaftlichen
systems und zwar in den stunden nach der
wahl und dann über wochen und monate mit
einer total chaotischen wahl die
irgendwann vielleicht mit einem
interesse zunächst mal mit einer
präsidentin pelosi möglicherweise endet
also das ist ja eine uralte verfassung
die da jetzt durchgezogen wird mit
später angepflanzten einzelbestimmungen
was in schlimmen fällen passiert hat man
immer mal wieder dran gedacht was machen
wir dann und dann haben wir wieder was
dazu geschrieben
völlig undurchsichtiges verfahren und
das wäre ja noch gut wenn das wäre wie
2000 jahren dazu entschieden hat und das
war alles blieb zivilisiert diesmal kann
es tatsächlich und al gore hat am ende
als er noch nicht musste gesagt ich gebe
jetzt zu ich habe verloren
diesmal wird es in den straßen der
städte und des landes nicht mehr
friedlich zu geben ist meine befürchtung
das heißt sie haben diese bemerkung von
donald trump zu den preis auch als eine
drohung empfunden
er ist jedenfalls nicht bereit den
einsatz solcher mittel von vornherein
abzulehnen und verbreitet damit eine
tiefe unsicherheit unter leuten die die
sich sorgen machen und vielleicht kommt
es zu einem wettbewerb wo irgendwann mal
die frage stellt ob der vernünftigere
nachgibt und trump hat keine kandidatur
wenn es darum geht wird der
vernünftigere ist um ein blutiges
desaster zu beenden
und ja man hätte in ihren augen die
macht tatsächlich bewaffnete auf die
straßen zu bringen
er hat nicht die macht kann es einfach
nur mit so einer haltung
es wäre nicht das erste mal dass er sagt
das war im wahlkampf 2016 hat er gesagt
ihr freunde des zweiten
verfassungszusatzes dass der der die
bären bewaffnete beamte die haltet euch
bereit dass da kein fehler passiert am
wahltag das ist ein ziemlich klare
aufrufen
und auch diesmal da passt das ins schema
wieder dass marina weisband ist bei uns
von bündnis 90/die grünen autoren
publizistin die leute verbinden sie über
noch mit den piraten da sind sie längst
nicht mehr sondern jetzt bei den grünen
verweist man in amerika sorgt man sich
über manipulationen und verschwörungen
aus russland und aus china
dabei hat dieses land selber genug
verschwörungs ideologen ja absolut wir
haben als also ich würde sogar herr
kleber aussage noch ein bisschen
erweitern ich glaube damit knapp hat
absolut die macht viele bewaffnete in
die straßen zu bringen und das liegt
daran dass er um sicherung eine art
politischen kult aufgebaut hat der
verschiedene arme hat wir haben
militante rassistische gruppierungen wie
die white boysen andere die ich nicht
nennen will
wir haben den verschwörungs kultkino der
wächst zwar nicht so stark in die breite
aber in die tiefe und wir wissen
inzwischen dass eine mehrheit der
republikanischen wähler innen das für
größtenteils richtig hält diese
verschwörungstheorie und das ist eine
antisemitische rassistische
verschwörungstheorie mit evangelikalen
ziehen und so eine endzeit erzählung das
ist tatsächlich da soll es einen
diebstahl geben also an den staat im
staate und es wird kindern an llanos der
zirbeldrüse enorm verschwörungstheorien
und fernsehen wieder geben es immer so
eine zwiespältige sache aber es ist ein
sehr altes klischee es sind die kinder
fressen juden die dort zurückgekommen
sind ein neuer gewandung und womit das
natürlich einfach zu tun hat ist dass
menschen es gibt menschen die neigen
dazu wenn die welt kompliziert ist sich
das möglichst einfach zu erklären dass
hinter chaotischen ereignissen
eigentlich ein kampf gut gegen böse
steckt und diese menschen haben sich
jetzt entschieden
donald trump ist der gute und der kämpft
heimlich gegen diese horden des diebs
tate also gegen das den staat im staat
und wenn da kinder gefoltert werden dann
ist das eine implizite aufforderung zu
gewalt
es sind sehr sehr viele menschen
schätzungen
es ist schwer zu heben aber sagen so
fünf bis sieben prozent aller amerikaner
hängen dieser theorie an und sie hat
sich nach deutschland verbreitet sie
versuchte moment die gelb westen
bewegung die anti corona bewegung zu
schlucken
sie heftet sich an verschiedene rechte
bewegungen und wenn wir uns vorstellen
eine so angespannte atmosphäre einen
präsidenten der alle regeln brechen will
der auf gar keinen fall freiwillig
seinen platz räumen will und der der
messias ist für einen kult der bewaffnet
ist dann ist es einfach das gesetz der
großen zahlen dass aller
wahrscheinlichkeit nach irgendwas
passieren wird fragen wir nochmal peter
rau ich will sie nicht fragen ob sie
auch glauben dass donald trump von einem
dieb state also diesem staat im staate
bedroht wird
aber immerhin spricht auch das fbi von
einer potenziellen terroristischen
bedrohung
andere institute von einer gefahr für
die nationale sicherheit sehen sie das
auch also ich denke das wird etwas
überbewertet
die übernahme ist für mich nicht nur
eine randgruppe der verschwörungs truppe
ich habe das erste mal für ein paar
monate davon gehört als ein deutscher
kollege der in brüssel sitzt mich
darüber gefragt hat es wird manchmal mit
der tea party verkriechen das finde ich
auch völlig absurd die
tea-party-bewegung 2010 den kongress mit
zurückerobert da haben etliche führende
republikaner ihren staat bekommen marco
rubio energie harry unser retter die
haben ein politisches programm gehabt
dass sich vertieft und ausgebaut hat
über die jahre angefangen mit dem
gesundheitssystem kritik und kion hat
mit pädophilie und so weiter zu tun also
das ist ja ein völlig absurdes thema hat
auch nichts mit der wahl diesmal zu tun
wir haben glaube ich eine vorwahl in
deutschland geschlagen mit seiner
abgeordneten- und glaube nicht auf der
basis funktionen sondern was sie ist
anscheinend eine anhängerin aber hat die
vorwahl gewonnen und die meisten das
gewusst haben weiß ich nicht und so weit
ich es weiß in den meinungsumfragen da
habe ich auch ein bisschen herum gefragt
gibt es unter den meisten amerikanern
keine kenntnisse in tokio an
umso mehr werde ich sagen in rücksprache
mit republikanern in washington und
viele haben sich auch schon öffentlich
geäußert so wie auch innen institutionen
hinein in den militär- und so weiter
würde niemand garantieren dass jetzt ein
präsident der abgewählt worden ist
einfach im amt bleiben können also wir
sind ja nicht mal ich weiß
da tun sich einbunkern gut er kann leute
aufrufen auf die straße aber da gibt es
auch einen widerspruch wenn das kommt
wirklich um die finanziellen interessen
geht und dass wir die mir immer wieder
vorgeworfen
dann was passiert zur marke trump was
passiert so die hotels sowie golfplätze
und so weiter beim namen trump und das
ist ja letztendlich das was für ihn
finanzielle auch zählt wenn er sich hier
mit einer miliz bande zurück auf die
straße gestellt und versucht den staat
zu bekämpfen das ist völlig absurd dass
wirklich stattfinden die republikaner
werden einen harten wahlkampf führen
dass werden grenzen überschritten auf
beide seite heute gibt es in der
internet seite von joe biden ein t shirt
zu kaufen halt die klappe müsste
präsident weil das von den debatten
abend kommt also spiele hierbei eine
ziemlich harte worte aber am tag nach
der wahl oder zumindest in den wochen
danach werden beide seiten die chancen
haben mit rechtlichen mitteln einen
wahlkampf anzukämpfen aber letztendlich
werden beide zur kenntnis nehmen müssen
so wie jo baiers gesagt habe am
wahlabend um mittlerweile dadurch schon
auch schon öfters privat und auch in der
öffentlichkeit gesagt habe wenn ich
gewinne
also es kann auch in einer niederlage
kommen und dann wird der neue präsident
ins amt kommen am 20 jänner da bin ich
sicher
aber er hat natürlich auch unterstellt
dass es dann nur eine wahlmanipulation
sein könnte dazu kommen wir noch dieser
wirtschaftliche aspekt spielt eine große
rolle klar
offensichtlich fühlt sich donald trump
ja auch von den steuerbehörden verfolgt
er bilder von 750 dollar
irgendwie recherchiert dass er keine bis
geringe steuern zahlen weil er hoch
verschuldet ist nimmt ihm das auch diese
dieses image als perfekte unternehmen ja
sollte man meinen ist aber nicht so weil
inzwischen die lager so eingefressen
sind in ihrer position dass das sich
bewahrheitet was not vor vier jahren
gesagt hat ich könnte auf der fifth
avenue jemand erschießen wer würde
nichts passieren
und das hat sich tatsächlich
bewahrheitet die leute die ihn wählen
die sich fest für ihn entschieden haben
die finden das sympathisch die wollen
auch lieber keine steuern zahlen und
jetzt ist ihr held mal so weit gekommen
und hat wahrscheinlich
millioneneinkommen und hat es irgendwie
geschafft diesem verdammten staat kein
geld abzugeben
das finden die schrecklich das finden
die r v
und hat er nun millionen gezahlt oder
hat er nicht millionen gezahlt keiner
weiß dass er behauptet millionen gezahlt
haben wahrscheinlich würde es dadurch
nicht
wahrscheinlich wird es nicht marina
weisband an versuchen diesen präsidenten
zu entlarven ihm beizukommen donald
trump zu entlarven gehabt irgendwie
unzählige er hat sogar ein impairment
verfahren durchgestanden ist er
unverwundbar ist er um in ihrem bild zu
bleiben jemand der in drachenblut
gebadet hat durch entlassung ist er
völlig unverwundbar
schauen sie jeder satz den donald trump
sagt zielt darauf ab den status quo zu
zerstören und die menschen mögen das
weil sie fühlen und zwar übrigens ich
möchte unterstellen auf beiden seiten in
beiden parteien fühlen sie dass der
status quo nicht mehr adäquat ist was
völlig richtig ist weil die
amerikanische politik beide parteien
nicht mehr antworten auf die fragen des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts haben ich
habe vorhin von kuehn angesprochen diese
art von endzeit kulten sehen wir immer
wenn die zeiten sich schnell ändern
komplexe probleme heranrollen und wenn
reichtum sehr sichtbar ist aber
unerreichbar
und das ist genau in den staaten im
moment der fall das heißt die menschen
sind unzufrieden und merken so wie
bisher geht das system nicht weiter das
heißt jeder der das system zerstört der
also zu diesem ehrenvollen duell als
riesiger wilder bär mit einer keule
kommt wird gefeiert und das einzige was
dagegen helfen könnte ist nicht mal der
hat gelogen
guck mal da ein verbrechen begangen das
macht ihn stark
das ist das was seine anhänger an ihm
schätzen was helfen würde wäre eine
gegen ansage
das wäre eine vision wir wollen die welt
so und so wir machen jetzt green new
deal
wir schließen die lücke zwischen arm und
reich antikorruptionsgesetze verbessert
das leben der menschen so dass sie es
spüren
und dann geht das weg damit sind wir bei
der entscheidenden frage sigmar gabriel
wie kommt man so jemandem politisch bei
haben sich die demokraten in amerika zu
lange daran ausgetobt ihm juristisch als
zeug zu flicken
das politisch bei einer erst mal muss
man akzeptieren das
damit scheint nicht die ursache der
spaltung amerikas ist sondern er ist
sozusagen ein symptom dafür haben gerade
kurz über die tea party bewegung
gesprochen
die jetzt ja auch nicht gerade ein
ausbund republikanischen mainstreams
gewesen ist
die radikalisierung die tiefe spaltung
in den usa gibt es viel länger und sie
hat soziale gründe nicht jede
interpretation dessen was menschen
erleben mag richtig sein aber dass ich
leute abgehängt fühle ich meine wir
haben eine in ländlichen regionen sinkt
die lebenserwartung junger männer und
zwar weil sie drogenabhängig werden
warum werden sie drogenabhängig
weil es in den usa möglich ist dass für
jedes kleine für den kleinen schmerz man
ein opiat verschrieben bekommt solange
die krankenkasse zahlt ist das schön
nicht wenn nicht mehr steigen die um auf
die ersatzdroge heroin ein riesenproblem
was ist die interpretation von menschen
na ja da hat die pharmaindustrie in
washington sich mal wieder durchgesetzt
denn die zum teil wissen die dass so was
in deutschland und europa verboten ist
also es gibt schon auch mal anlässe
dafür dass das land auseinander fällt
dort muss eben bei einer hohen
arbeitslosigkeit wie sie jetzt durch
corona entstanden ist muss helikopter
geld herum geflogen werden weil es keine
arbeitslosen versicherung gibt weil es
kein kurzarbeitergeld gibt weil es keine
gesetzliche krankenversicherung gibt und
das führt natürlich dazu dass menschen
verunsichert sind sich die gesellschaft
sich spaltet und ein teil davon ist
genauso wie sie das beschrieben haben
rennt dann dem heilsbringer hinterher
und es hätten die demokraten anders
machen müssen dann erstmals auf erstens
aufhören zu glauben
wladimir putin hätte jump an die macht
gebracht ich meine da klar hat er darum
gefummelt und das wird er jetzt auch
wieder machen
aber weil natürlich weil putin erdogan
die finden das super wenn dort mit tram
präsident bleibt weil sie die gleiche
sicht auf die welt haben weil die welt
einer arena ist bei der der cash
stärkere sich durchsetzt ein präsident
der wieder allianzen schmieden würde auf
der welt ist für die viel schwieriger zu
handeln aber verloren haben die
demokraten weil sie über clinton über
die details geredet hat weil das
sozusagen eine elite war die abgänge die
abgehängten weil sie nicht weil sie sich
verrannt haben in die politik haben die
sozialen bedürfnisse der menschen nicht
mehr adressiert das ist der grund warum
die demokraten wie übrigens viele andere
progressive linksliberale
sozialdemokratische parteien verloren
haben und nicht deshalb weil trump super
war
und obama ist schon gewählt worden
er ist schon gewählt worden als jemand
der gegen das establishment ist der kam
nicht aus washington
der kam aus chicago wunderbare
berichterstattung einer deutschen
journalistin im zweiten wahlgang von
obama war die frage ist amerika noch
rassistisch und der klopft die so macht
eine camperin begleitet die die klingel
dann kommt eine hausfrau und dann redet
ihr auf die einen den soll obama werde
irgendwann dreht sich um und ruft ins
wohnzimmer
wenn wir noch mehr wählen und dann wird
er beschrieben so ein redneck mit einer
bierdose der schreit zurück nach der
entega natürlich weil weil sozusagen das
dass die bewegung gegen die da oben war
wichtiger ist ja was ist und da da da
setzt jump drauf und das war irgendwie
war übrigens das was wir hier so schlimm
finden an dem duell war aus seiner sicht
ein gelungener wahlkampf und darum sagte
auch er würde sich nicht an die neuen
regeln halten die man jetzt für die
nächsten zwei duelle eröffnen
probieren sie spezialisieren und sind
absolute kennerin eigentlich dieses
transatlantischen verhältnis ist dass es
ihr arbeitsschwerpunkt hätten sie
erwartet dass hier jetzt hier irgendwie
so kurz vor der wahl nach vier vollen
jahren amtszeit sitzen und uns sorgen
machen dass donald trump sogar noch
einmal gewählt werden könnte also das
kommt darauf an wann sie mich gefragt
hätten hätten sie mich das vor vier
jahren anfang september gefragt dann
hätte ich dass wir völlig absurd
gehalten wer gesagt 2016 war für meine
zunft tatsächlich einen grund noch mal
tief in uns zu gehen und uns zu
überdenken
ich finde jetzt wäre das die einzige
logische konsequenz der letzten vier
jahre wenn donald trump am tag der wahl
sagen würde er erkennt das wahlergebnis
nur dann an wenn er gewonnen hat
und das ist eigentlich die wirkliche
gefahr die ich sehe ich sehe gar nicht
kennen und so ich stimmt peter auffällig
zu das ist glaube ich eine
randerscheinung trotz allem ich sehe das
problem eher wenn am wahltag selber die
so aussieht als würde donald trump
gewinnen und unheimlich viele amerikaner
aber briefwahl gemacht haben und im
nachhinein sich das kräfteverhältnis
verändert und joe biden gewinnen wird
dann dass er das dann nicht anerkennt
das ist für mich die ja die größere
herausforderung und da würde ich sagen
da ist alles möglich dass er wirklich
bis zum letzten blutstropfen darauf
besteht dass er der einzige und wahre
präsident der vereinigten staaten
persönlich verfolgt fühlt sich diese
präsidenten eines sacks hinzufügt petra
werden permanent von von
rechtsextremismus und das kann sein dass
dies lag den sich dann manifestiert nach
der wahl aber wir haben jetzt
gegenwärtig mit linksextremismus sehr zu
spielen also in den letzten paar monaten
laut versicherungs anträgen damals über
eine milliarde dollar schaden
angerichtet worden ist in den
großstädten leute die jetzt schon wütend
sind und auf die straße gehen und dann
rammt wegkam wollen weil er
überraschende reise die wahl trotzdem
doch noch gewinnt und das wäre ein
großer schock und eine überraschung laut
umfragen und die umfang licht sowie 2016
innerhalb der schwankungsbreite oder
annahmen einfach geändert werden müssen
das ist schon ein ziemlich großer
vorsprung von joe biden und dann würden
diese leute umso wütender auf die straße
gehen wie das ziel jetzt nicht gerade
auf versöhnung aus also für mich ist
eigentlich die größte befürchtung dass
damals schon die wahl gewinnt und
dadurch eben unter den linksextremisten
etwas auslöst was weitgehend mehr
organisiert mehr kräftig und den letzten
monaten schon geprüft und irgendwie die
probe dafür schon gelaufen ist claus
kleber sehen sie die sorge also es ist
eindeutig so dass die rechtsnationalen
kräfte in amerika besser als organisiert
besser bewaffnet besser geübt und so
weiter sind also nicht denken dass man
behaupten kann dass das was passiert ist
vor allen dingen in den demonstrationen
nach polizeigewalt
dass es in irgendeiner weise nennenswert
organisiert sei die befürchtung ist
tatsächlich und das müssen wir auch aus
deutschland natürlich versuchen mit
distanz und und gleichgewicht zu sehen
aber es ist eindeutig so dass die gefahr
von der anderen seite größer ist also
ich habe vor 30 jahren schon filme
gemacht über über diese bewegungen die
sich da am wochenende mit scharfen
waffen im wald vorbereiten und zwar
nicht um krieg spiele zu machen sollen
sondern um ein unrechtsstaat zu stürzen
das ist die mission
da geht es nicht um irgendein abstraktes
recht ich will mein gold zu hause haben
falls ein einbrecher kommt sondern die
philosophie dieser gruppen ist wir
müssen im zweifel stärker sein als der
start um ihn runter ringen zu können
auch wenn er mit seinen polizeitruppen
ankommt deshalb sehen diese braut boys
zb besser bewaffnet aus als
polizeieinheiten denn die demonstrieren
zwei dinge erstens das ist ja dass die
strategie der republikanischen partei
ein äquivalent zu schaffen zwischen
leuten die aus wut darüber dass menschen
willkürlich in ihren betten teilweise
ermordet werden von der polizei
sachbeschädigung machen und menschen die
losziehen und andere menschen töten für
das was sie sind und wie sie geboren
sind und diese äquivalenz sehen wir auch
in deutschland manchmal aufkommen und
das ist genau die gefahr
und das zweite ist dass trump hat
tatsächlich auch gesagt hat seine
anhänger aufgefordert hat in die
wahlkabinen zu gehen und zu gucken ob
alles richtig abläuft und das ist nichts
geringeres als eine aufforderung zur
einschüchterung und damit sind wir bei
einem dritten punkt von dem sich trump
persönlich verfolgt fühlt dem corona
virus nämlich da war doch was
kaum ein land hat corona so hart
getroffen wie die usa mehr als 200.000
tote
doch statt krisen management betreibt
der präsident lieber das blame game
wir müssen die nation zur verantwortung
ziehen die diese plage auf die welt
losgelassen hat china die anderen nicht
er dabei ist er der präsident der
falsche präsident schimpft ex first lady
michelle obama dabei wusste tram früh um
die gefahr des virus das sagt rampf
selbst in einem telefoninterview anfang
februar
das virus sei sehr gefährlich tödlicher
als die grippe doch er behielt ist für
sich ich wollte es immer herunterspülen
ich will das noch immer herunter spielen
weil ich keine panik erzeugen möchte
200.000 tote 7 millionen infizierte als
man ihm diese zahl nannte sagte er
so ist es ja es ist so weil sie so sind
darum ist es so der präsident hat keinen
plan und dieses telefon interview war
ende märz und nicht anfang februar frage
zu peter rau ist corona der
gefährlichste politische feind für den
präsidenten ja sicherlich also ableiten
davon auch hat es ja auch das prozedere
des wahlkampfs völlig verändert er kann
ich diese große veranstaltungen
durchführen wie er es gerne möchte und
joe biden hat sich können verabschieden
sich ein punkt kann in der allgäuer in
sein haus und dadurch sich selbst dürfen
ins knie schießen sozusagen und joe
biden da ja im spiegel freien bei wochen
glaube ich in der titelgeschichte als
labil und müde beschrieben worden ist da
sicherlich nicht mehr am zenit seiner
macht natürlich dürfen verabschieden
trump hat nicht können den wahlkampf
führen
denn er wollte und natürlich ist die
wirtschaft auch eingebrochen das war ja
ein hauptargument das donald trump ihr
verbringen wollte aber ich möchte auch
vielleicht hinzufügen wir sind auch ein
föderales land und unsere länder haben
ja die hauptkompetenz der bund muss
unterstützen
ich sage das nicht als ausrede sondern
einfach um einmal im blick zu behalten
wenn jemand wäre er unbedingt alle macht
an sich reißen möchte
er hätte ein bisher krise völlig anders
gehandelt und teilweise die öffentliche
bundeskompetenz ausgebaut wie zum
beispiel mann viktor orban
das hat überhaupt nicht stattgefunden
jump hat sich zurückgezogen die länder
gestärkt kalifornien in new york
unterstützt aber weitgehend eigentlich
die bundesregierung in einer hauptrolle
eingebrockt interessanter punkt claus
kleber würden sie auch sagen er hat
damit nachgewiesen ein miserabler
manager zu sein oder ist es für die
amerikaner gar nicht so wichtig dieses
corona virus auch wenn 206.000 menschen
gestorben sind
also ich war seit ausbruch von diskursen
virus leider nicht in usa haben das ist
es schwierig geworden dort hinzukommen
aber ich kriege aus meinen kontakten in
amerika mit dass das thema dort viel
belasteter ist als bei uns das steckt
den menschen wirklich in den knochen
weil die zahlen eben ganz andere sind
und weil sie das gefühl haben dass ihre
regierung damit nicht fertig wird
die schauen jetzt mit großer bewunderung
diejenigen die ins ausland schauen das
sind ja bei weitem nicht alle aber die
schauen mit großer bewunderung auf
europa und speziell auf deutschland aber
ich glaube das gibt schon einen ganz
enorm beklemmendes gefühl
und das hilft dem amtierenden
präsidenten nicht es ist so am ende ist
in amerika doch immer der präsident
schuld was wieder raus sagt ist sachlich
richtig aber am ende der backstop sehr
schlag mal stand bei das schildchen aber
aus alten zeiten noch auf dem resolut sk
auf dem der also denn seine
amtsgeschäfte führt und die
verantwortung landet immer hier als und
trump versucht die da immer so wieder
vom tisch zu schieben die macht ja die
verantwortung nicht und trotzdem muss
man ja fragen herr gabriel sind es
tatsächlich rams tote oder ist nicht ein
furchtbares gesundheitssystem daran
schuld
erstmal ist es natürlich
unverantwortlich gewesen wir am anfang
mit der krise umgegangen ist und
übrigens hat das weltweit folgen gehabt
denn wenn wir jetzt mal erinnern was war
bei der letzten großen krise der fall
der finanzkrise 28 trafen sich sofort
die g20-finanzminister macht eine
gemeinsame krisen analyse und
marschierten dann miteinander los hier
gab es einen außenminister treffen waren
sich nicht mal eigentlich wie man den
virus nennen soll bald darauf bestanden
hat das dass der hahn virus oder der
china virus ist weil er ihnen sozusagen
innerhalb der usa braucht er ein gegner
damit er nicht verantwortlich und ich
glaube das wird jetzt noch passieren
ich vermute er wird zwei große konflikte
noch mal fahren einen mit china und
einen innerstaatlichen weil er feinde
braucht und dann wird die frage sein
vor der sich wähler für diese wähler
gestellt sind wenn es wirklich wenn es
sozusagen äußeren und eine innere
bedrohung gibt die ihr versuchen wird zu
inszenieren
dann werden die wähler sagen wer wird
uns da besser durch steuern und das ist
sozusagen die schwäche von beiden und
darauf will er hinaus er wir sozusagen
sich als den vitalen verteidiger
amerikanischer interessen gegen die
feinde amerikas im innern und im außen
nach außen darstellen und darauf hofft
er dass dann sozusagen das nochmal kippt
zugunsten einer wahl in diesen wenigen
staaten die ja nur gewinnen muss und
dafür ist china ganz wichtig für ihn das
ist das sind sozusagen das land aus dem
das ganze übel kommt einschließlich des
virus ok und damit sind wir bei joe
biden dem herausforderer frau weiß band
und wir haben sie eingangs zitiert mit
dem satz dass er im grunde als
gegenkandidat
wir haben die gesagt irrelevant ist
reicht es sich zu stilisieren als ein
anti tram im moment ja dass also das
meinten das ist was ich im vorgespräch
meinte mit es ist im prinzip wie
relevant am tag der wahl wer da steht so
lange es eben nicht trump ist deswegen
ich glaube dass es tatsächlich so ist
ich glaube dass jemand der eine stärkere
eigene vision vertritt der stärker
selber weg geht von dem weiter wie
bisher
es war trump sehr viel wind aus den
segeln nehmen konnte aber andererseits
weniger vom zentrum mitnehmen würde also
es ist schwierig es könnte sein dass
beiden tatsächlich der demokraten
sie standen ja von einer ganz wichtigen
frage und wie wurde auch sehr strittig
auch diese und die zahlen menschen waren
da unheimlich wichtig die umfragen
machten und die stimmung im volk
analysierten gehen wir jetzt gegen trump
mit jemand vor der die leute begeistert
vereine für eine linke idee eine neue
vision von amerika bernie sanders
[Musik]
elizabeth warren die namen muss man in
deutschland gar nicht unbedingt kennen
das sind die die diese linken hurra wir
bauen amerika um und die andere schule
sagten gottes will das hat noch niemand
zahl ist wir brauchen jemand auf denen
die verunsicherten leute sagen können
der wird schon nicht mehr rückt jetzt
alles wieder beruhigen er ist keine
sozialleistung und dafür haben sie sich
entschieden das ist wählbarkeit die
mobilisierung und das könnte ein fehler
gewesen jetzt für die demokratische
partei die war ja extrem zerstritten
auch zersplittert und konnte hier jeder
markt und er und es ist glaube ich auch
keiner mag doch nicht alle haben wir
jetzt dabei den umfragen darauf die
fragen ja ich sag mir ein bei den
demokraten aber bei den demokraten ist
trump auch der eine faktor also man hat
sich auf die beiden jetzt geeinigt und
gesagt dass es unser mann und wir
stärken den jetzt deswegen haben diese
splitter kämpfe auch weitgehend auf
vizepräsident gemacht jemanden der nicht
auf der linken seite zu verorten ist
eine strafe staatsanwältin verloren oder
der dass seine flanke das ist übrigens
ein punkt im duell wo ich fand wo beiden
ziemlich in der defensive war wogegen
bei der kohle kommt beim corona thema
eher stärken hatte und mit dieser
entscheidung ist bestätigt worden wir
wollten einen zentristischen kurs fahren
war sozusagen es ja nichts nützt wenn
sie die hardcore anhänger mobilisieren
und die alle gute laune haben aber eben
es dann nur in dem kleinen kreisel und
die anderen trump versucht jetzt dafür
sagt das ist der schwache beine
der ist wirklich eine marionette sleepy
dog und dem hintergrund sind die
sozialisten die also schwedische
verhältnisse in amerika einführen würden
sie doch am besten eine demokraten und
genau die ist uns jetzt zugeschaltet aus
atlanta in georgia
angelika kaufen nämlich sie ist
gebürtige wuppertalerin seit 2011 us
bürgerin und aus protest gegen donald
trump ist sie seit 2017 in die politik
gegangen und ist jetzt quasi landtags
abgeordnete der demokraten in georgia
frau einen schönen guten abend zu ihnen
wir packen jetzt alles zusammen und
fangen mit ihrer persönlichen geschichte
an
sie und ihr mann waren beide krone
infiziert glauben denn die amerikaner
glauben die mehrheitlich dass jemand wie
joe biden für allein weniger chor ohne
tote besorgt hätte also das ist sehr
schwer zu sagen der korona virus hier
betrifft uns alle ganz persönlich also
mich persönlich unserer familie
persönlich weil ich mit einem betroffen
waren und ihr somit wissen was dieser
virus machen kann
ich würde sagen so hypothetische fragen
bringen uns nicht weiter er dann was ich
in meinem bezirk sehe und ich kann das
ja nur lokal sagen ist dass die leute
hier wollen eine antwort haben und
wollen uns weiter wollen dass die
politiker eine antwort den gewinnern
geben wie geht es weiter wie kommen wir
zurück zum neuen normalität
wir bekämpfen sie diesen virus so dass
wir zu unserem normalen leben
zurückkehren können und im großen und
ganzen was ich aus meinem bezirk sehe
und was ich aus von meinem umkreis sehe
und ich bin in einem der der meist
umkämpften bezirke in einem swing
bezirke im nordosten der von metro
atlanta dass die leute sagen okay joe
biden ist der bessere kandidat weil er
glaubt an die wissenschaft er hätte
einen mehr wissenschaftlichen angeführt
und außerdem dass in diesem umfeld wo
wir wo wir uns bewegen mit einem
unberechenbaren und trump jemand wie
beiden uns einfach wieder in ruhigere
gewässer bringt und das ist das was die
leute eigentlich wollen so richtig
begeisterung für joe biden kommt auch
hier in deutschland nicht anfrage auch
an sie frau aus reicht es wenn jemand
nur in anführungsstrichen ein anti trump
ist also joe biden ist deutlich mehr als
ein anti trump und er ist als kandidat
aufgestellt worden für die demokraten
weil er halt jahrelange erfahrung mit
sich bringt und auch leute wissen wer
ist und vor allen dingen wir sind hier
an in atlanta in der
wiege des civil rights movement mit
starker schwarzer beteiligung in der
politik
die heimat von jean-louis denn und
dieses jahr gestorben ist
hier verstehen die leute wer joe biden
ist und er hat hier sehr große
unterstützung unter den den den
schwarzen amerikanern und das hat ihnen
letztlich vor angeschafft weil die leute
ihm vertrauen sie wissen wer so ist wenn
man den namen joe biden wird muss keiner
nachdenken wer ist das denn und hält
sondern sie wissen ganz genau für was er
steht und man kennt ihn und warum nur um
die frage aufzunehmen erschien es den
demokraten so abwegig jemanden wie
kämmerer herres zu nominieren
das sind einfach da muss man den
amerikanischen walfang wahlkampf für
verstehen camilla harris hat natürlich
vor allen dingen bei den bei den
schwarzen amerikanern 1 1 ein problem
weil sie als vor vorherige
staatsanwältinnen natürlich immer ein
bisschen in der diskussion ist so leute
sagen sie hat leute ins gefängnis
gebracht
und wenn man die amerikanische das
amerikanische rechtssystem kennt
natürlich sind hauptsächlich oder wenn
man die meisten leute die in den
gefängnissen sind sind halt
wir haben eine große schwarze mehrheit
die halt verurteilt wird das ist ein
systematisches problem was jetzt auch in
diesem black live smooth movement wieder
rausgekommen ist
und deswegen hat mir ein bisschen
problem mit kameras ist das interessant
ist aber zu sehen dass sie jetzt alle
100 prozent hinter dem ticket beiden
herres dahinter stehen und zahlen meine
meine kollegen hier african americans in
atlanta sehr sehr sehr sehr befürworten
zu unterstützen ok samt möchte unbedingt
seine kandidaten für den supreme court
jetzt durchdrücken
frage an die demokraten hätte dass ihre
partei nicht genauso gemacht wenn sie
die mehrheit hätte das hat ja obama
versucht und das haben sie ihn nicht
erlaubt natürlich ist immer so dass die
die partei die an der mehrheit ist
versucht ihren kandidaten durchzubringen
darf er das ist halt so ist das
amerikanische system ist auch
konditionell das problem dabei ist dass
republikaner letztendlich das geschafft
haben wo sie jahrzehntelang darauf
hingearbeitet haben
das heißt die die gerichte mit
konservativen richtern zu besetzen
und im grunde ist meine frage an die
republikaner warum wollt ihr eigentlich
ein tramp noch wieder wählen ihr habt
doch alles erreicht was ihr wollt ihr
habt die konservative richter in den
meisten fällen oder kurz also den und
ihr habt also jetzt einen konservativen
richter am supreme court
damit könnt ihr die sachen erreichen für
die ihre ansteht und das ist vielleicht
für deutsche zuhörer nicht so nicht so
offensichtlich aber es ist hier also die
sie zurück die die abwägung oder diesen
den repeater abtreibungsgesetze und vor
allen dingen auch die möglichkeit
obamacare wieder zurückzuholen also
abzuwählen und wieder abzuwählen
wir danken ganz herzlich angelika
keusche nach atlanta für diese
einschätzung und geben sofort weiter an
peter rau musste es auch deshalb mit
dieser besetzung so schnell gehen für
den supreme court soll es deshalb so
schnell gehen weil ausgerechnet diese
supreme court eine entscheidende rolle
spielen könnte wenn es um die
rechtmäßigkeit des wahlergebnisses geht
das ist voll besetzt ist sicherlich
würde ich schon sagen aber es geht auch
darum dass man laut verfassung der
präsident jemand präsentieren kann und
dass der nagel sind die darüber
abstimmen möchte bevor es ein
regierungswechsel gibt anfang jänner
2021 derweil haben die republikaner noch
die mehrheiten aber vielleicht um die
frage zu beantworten die rega den
republikanern gestellt worden ist warum
wird möchte man da halt nochmal wählen
oder die republikaner im senat und im
abgeordnetenhaus und wenn man da hinein
blickt in die strukturen der
demokratischen partei ist es nicht so
wie claus kleber gerade sich lächerlich
über die republikaner gemacht hat wir
wollen schweden sondern da kann man
schon manche sachen die einen
beunruhigen man möchte das supreme court
möglicherweise ausbauen mehr richter
besetzen
unser wichtigster präsident des
zwanzigsten jahrhundert franklin
roosevelt hat damals mit diesen gedanken
gespielt und wird bis heute damit ab
bestraft in den geschichtsbüchern
obwohl es nicht vollzogen hat man möchte
möglich war ist der neue senat 17
verleiten in den senat puerto rico
washington dc
man möchte möglicherweise das touro
college abschaffen damit will sie jetzt
auch gespielt 2016 hat man gesehen ein
signal vom ländlichen raum dass diese
leute sich abgehängt für ihn jetzt
werden nur noch wahlkampf führen in den
großstädten oder den einwohner reichen
bundesländern man möchte dass speer
mechanismus im senat das wissen die
dezidiert abschaffen dass es der
opposition ermöglicht anträge zu
blockieren das sind alles grundsätze
unserer demokratie an denen hier
gegraben und gesägte dass es ist nicht
so einfach zu sagen ja da geht es um die
körperschaftssteuer prozent der oder ob
man in den bereichen klimaschutz
einkommen wieder einsteigt das ist
leicht in berlin heute das einen aber
die sichtweise dass washington nicht
muss vier jahre mit dieser
innenpolitischen dann umgehen und leben
haben die schon mehr geschafft die
demokraten als sie eigentlich zu geben
und hat donald trump das land schon viel
mehr verändert als wir alle glauben
donald trump hat das land ganz sicher
verändert und hat einer schicht das ist
der fehler den die demoskopen die
politologen und die journalistin 2016
gemacht haben dass wir alle unterschätzt
haben
die tiefe überzeugung einer großen eines
großen teils der amerikaner dass das
land in der falschen richtung unterwegs
ist und in eine unchristliche und
gottesfürchtige nicht mehr an amerika
glaubende alles gleich machen art dass
das alles was sicher war nicht mehr
sicher ist dass in dorchester hat ihm
geholfen das zu brechen und es gibt
viele amerikaner leute die hier häufig
ausgelacht werden mit denen wir aber von
ihrer ausbildung von ihrem von ihrem
leben uns gerne befreunden das sind
anwälte steuerberater ärzte für die iss
ein problem ist täglich ein problem in
einem land zu leben in dem abtreibung
möglich ist das widerspricht allem wofür
sie stehen und die meinen das sehr angst
und wir hatten schon aufgegeben
die dachten dass wird jetzt hat so
bleiben und jetzt kommt's trump der nun
wirklich nicht die verkörperung des
christlichen weges darstellt und ist
aber offensichtlich das werkzeug gottes
der sünder als werkzeug gottes ist eine
ganz alte vorstellung um das land wieder
auf den weg dazu die zurückzubringen
und für die ist zb die abtreibung und
die chance jetzt ein neuer supreme court
die abtreibung wieder schwerer macht
ist wichtiger als jeder
körperschaftssteuersatz als das pariser
abkommen als benachteiligung von
irgendwas und als die konjunktur und die
man darf diese leute nicht ausmachen die
meinen das sehr ernst
das ist eine werte entscheidung geht die
mehrheit der deutschen nicht teilen
würde inzwischen aber früher auch mal
geteilt hat und das ist das ressort aus
dem jump dazu kommt ja noch der umbau
der republikanischen partei ist ist ja
nicht nur die wähler sondern trump hat
es ja in vier jahren geschafft diese
republikaner in einen trump fan verein
zu verwandeln und jeden ausgeschaltet an
entscheidenden positionen der ihm
widerspricht dass er sein haben wir eine
seines scharf von robotern die jetzt
einfach in richtung mehrheit laufen da
sind gestandene leute wie mitt romney
einziger im der plötzlich umgekehrt ist
also gestand ist den autoren mit mitt
romney wollten wir jetzt gerne auch noch
mal anfangen über die zweifel an der
wahl zu reden denn diese amerikanische
präsident nährt auch zweifel an der
rechtmäßigkeit der wahl und vor allen
dingen an der briefwahl schauen
trumps parteifreund der republikanische
senator mitt romney und den präsidenten
fundamental für eine demokratie ist der
friedliche machtwechsel ohne den haben
wir belarus trump im falle einer
niederlage freiwillig geht seit monaten
sät er zweifel an der legitimität des
wahlergebnisses macht stimmung gegen die
briefwahl warnt vor dem größten betrug
der geschichte es werden wahlunterlagen
verkauft in flüssen versenkt schrecklich
für unser land das wird nicht gut
ausgehen
ich hoffe es wird eine faire wahl aber
wenn ich sehe dass zehntausende
wahlunterlagen manipuliert werden
dann kann ich da nicht mitziehen sie
betrügen belarus in washington
nichts ist ausgeschlossen für den
dritten november 2020
peter rau frage wieder ansehen wie groß
ist auch ihre sorge die mit rom nieder
formuliert hat nämlich die sorge dass es
einen friedlichen regelgerechten
übergang von macht geben könnte denn
wird es geben ich glaube da wäre joe
biden und donald trump elli wären da
isoliert wenn sie andere richtung
einschlagen möchten sicherlich ist das
eine enorme logistische herausforderung
die wir zurzeit haben das ist eine
briefwahl in einer dimension die bisher
in der vergangenheit nicht halten ist
natürlich mit mit der pandemie verbunden
und gerade deswegen wenn man ja die
bürokratie in washington und in anderen
bundesländern kennt ist man jetzt nicht
so optimistisch dass da alles perfekt
über die bühne laufen wird aber
letztendlich haben wir keine andere wahl
wir müssen das akzeptieren was kommt man
kann natürlich mit juristischen
rechtlichen schritten
da versuchen sein argument zu machen das
ist richtig so aber sobald das
ausgelotet wird da fallen alle
demokratischen und republikanischen
führung seien hätten weg denn der
präsident oder der herausforderer wird
zu akzeptieren müssen dass da ein neuer
präsident oder der alte wieder gewählt
also interessant sigmar gabriel
wenn donald trump am wahlabend zum
sieger erklärt wird oder wenn er sich
selber zum sieger erklärt und eigentlich
sind die briefwahl ergebnisse noch nicht
ausgezählt aus einzelnen staaten sind
die ergebnisse noch nicht da wer soll
diesen präsidenten dann auf halten wir
das ja schon richtig gesagt das ist eine
sehr komplizierte verfassungslage da und
darauf setzt er wahrscheinlich ersetzt
ja nicht darauf dass dann die
bewaffneten milizen losmarschieren und
das weiße haus besetzen sondern dass es
eine so komplizierte lage gibt dass im
zweifel der der klügere nachgibt und
dass joe biden auf so was glaube ich
setzt aber ich würde gerne meinen raum
als politikwissenschaftler ansprechen
nicht mehr da ist also so was dass das
sind sie ja eingeladen
ich bin ein bisschen entsetzt über die
leichtigkeit mit der sie über etwas
hinweg gehen was ich glaube was die
grundlagen jeder demokratischen
verfasstheit berührt nämlich dass ein
präsident ein amtierender präsident auf
die frage ob er das wahlergebnis
akzeptiert oder nicht keine klare
antwort
gibt sie kennen sicher sie kennen die
deutschen gut genug den
verfassungsrechtler blöcken fördert er
hat man bei uns gesagt die demokratie
braucht voraussetzungen die sie selber
nicht schaffen kann und dazu gehört die
akzeptanz von mehrheit und minderheit
wenn ein gewählter präsident nicht mal
mehr das bereit ist zu sagen ich finde
da muss man doch auch als republikaner
mal sagen da verlässt jemand die
grundlagen all dessen für was westliche
demokratie eigentlich steht und es gibt
zwei jungs die sich richtig darüber
freuen
der eine sitzt in peking und der anderen
moskau und ich finde man kann nicht so
tun haben
hertrampf und herr beiden werden sich
hinterher schon entscheiden beiden hat
nie infrage gestellt dass er sich
entscheidet
es gibt einen einzigen der erklärt ich
kann auch nicht sagen ob ich das
wählervotum akzeptiere und der heißt
dran und das ist eine das finde ich ja
tom friedman in der new york times gut
beschrieben das ist der eigentliche
skandal
und dass ein amtierender gewählter
präsident in frage stellt ob er das amt
verlässt wenn du nicht die mehrheit der
stimmen hat und er bereitet seit wochen
vor die delegitimierung des
wahlprozesses und das finde ich wenn man
als politikwissenschaftler geladen ist
da finde ich da mal was zu sagen oder
nicht darf ich beantworten oder
unbedingt sie müssen
ok ich wollte nur sagen wie ich wurden
ich sehe das überhaupt nicht mit
leichtigkeit ich weiß nicht warum sie
das verspüren mir wurde die frage
gestellt wie darauf reagiert würde man
hat ja schon vom mexikaner öffentlich
gehört man hat auch schon von juni die
nummer drei im repräsentantenhaus der
republikaner gehört es wird einen
geordneten übergang geben es heißt ist
existieren nicht die mittel für donald
trump wenn es aussieht ist es aus ich
habe schon vorhin gesagt wir sind nicht
mal es gibt hier bestimmte schranken
also damals schon können sagen und tun
was er will wenn er die wahl verliert
mit der verlieren und das gleiche gilt
auch für jogger hat es ja auch gesagt in
der debatte wie ich vorhin erwähnt habe
aber das gut es wurde also das stimmt ja
nur wenn es wirklich dann auch
irgendwann mal ein eindeutiges ergebnis
gibt wir erinnern uns an das jahr 2011
gegen bush gab und wo dann die gerichte
entschieden haben und fordern
tatsächlich die wahl niederlage
eingestanden hat zuvor also bevor es
überhaupt musste
so eine situation ist doch jetzt auch
durchaus denkbar dass ist ein ganz
knappes ergebnis wird das am wahlabend
trump der sieger ist er diskreditiert
diese briefwahl seit monaten er sagt
dies nicht verlässlich er ruft ja auch
die leute auf gar nicht briefwahl zu
machen er sagt kommt mal ins wahllokal
da kommt corona wieder rein die
republikaner glauben ja viel weniger an
corona die tramps selber trägt ja
niemals gehört das ist deswegen ist es
für ihn wichtig dass nicht so viele
leute zur wahl gehen das schafft ja
indem er so ein schreckensszenario
aufbaut deswegen gehen dann mehr
republikaner zur wahl
dann wird und die anderen machen
briefwahl dann wird er gewählt und dann
gibt es ja erst im nachhinein ein
teilweise vielleicht monate sich
hinziehen und prozess der und
unsicherheit und unklarheit
und da geht es dann nicht darum das ist
wirklich aufstände oder so gibt sondern
da geht es darum dann wird werden die
auszählungen hinterfragt und dann geht
es um das langsame unterwandern der
glaubwürdigkeit der gesamten wahl sind
relativ einfach eine politische
situation herzustellen nach dem wahltag
in dem das system tatsächlich nicht in
der lage ist einen präsidenten zu
produzieren die die sache was ich vorhin
sagte mit blut in den straßen das ist
nicht so dass am ende die stärkere
bürgerkriegspartei entscheidet werde das
ganz sicher nicht es steht nur ein
unheimlicher druck dieses problem zu
lösen man kann nicht weiterhin zu gucken
jeden abends in fünf neue statt den der
in den nachrichten die brennen wurde
innenstädte brennen oder teile davon
dass das gewinnen das setzt eben voraus
dass das oberste ziel die
funktionsfähigkeit dieses landes ist
aber trump ist gibt klar zu erkennen
dass sein oberstes ziel es ist die tram
präsidentschaft zu verlängern und dann
kommt lange nichts dann kommt vielleicht
wenn ich verliere ist manipulation und
sagte ja dann dann auch so heiter die
das ergebnis wenn das so eindeutig ist
das kein zweifel besteht man ja aber
jeden zweifel werde ich aus nun sind ja
aus 19 verweist noch einmal mitt romney
zitiert ohne friedlichen machtübergang
wäre es wie
wer also wo oppositionelle demokraten
gerade versuchen ein regime zu bekämpfen
egal ob man jetzt nach hongkong guckt
oder nach minsk oder nach moskau guckt
kann das eigentlich kann kann dieses
land mit diesem präsidenten noch ein
vorbild in bezug auf das sein wenn man
demokratischer oppositionelle fest es
kann durchaus sein dass er dann minsk
und kiew und hongkong zu vorbildern für
die amerikaner werden
also wenn das passiert was herr kleber
was eigentlich alle in dieser runde
völlig zu recht erwarten wenn die wahl
knapp wird wenn es zuerst am wahltag so
aussieht als ob trump gewinnt und dann
in diesen 79 tagen die es bis zur wahl
einführung gibt eine schlammschlacht um
stimmenauszählung legitimität
wenn es dazu verfahren kommt es wird in
dieser zeit sehr wahrscheinlich zu
gewalt kommen
und wenn es dann darum geht irgendwie
anzufechten dass eine wahl illegitim ist
oder dass das hier macht genommen wurde
auf undemokratische weise dann werden
amerikanerinnen auch sicherlich wieder
einen dauerprotest machen müssen und
dann werden sie sich an den methoden
bedienen die die ganzen anderen staaten
gemacht habe und das ist sehr schade für
die usa die damit sehr weit zurückfallen